يقف عبد الرشيد شوزاد في وادي
اللعين في مقاطعة
أوروزغان ، وكان قد أنهى لتوه
مهمة أخرى مع فريق الفقمة 10.
اللغوي الأفغاني الذي يعمل جنبًا إلى جنب مع
النخبة العسكرية الأمريكية
يترجم للقوات الخاصة الأمريكية ،
ولكن وفقًا لما قاله عبد الرشيد ، فإن سنوات خدمته الخمس
قد
بلغت الآن عقوبة الإعدام  بعد
أن رفضت الحكومة الأمريكية
تأشيرة الهجرة الخاصة
به ، مما جعله هدفًا لطالبان إذا أمسكوا
بي ،
فسوف يقتلونني وسيقتلون أطفالي وسيقتلون
زوجتي أيضًا.
أعرف
أن أبًا لثلاثة أطفال يقول إن عقده
مع الجيش الأمريكي
قد تم إنهاؤه في عام 2014 بعد أن فشل في
اختبار كشف الكذب
[موسيقى]
ولكن خطابات التوصية الخاصة به من
قادة الأختام
تعكس مترجمًا
تجاوز واجباته
واصفاً إياه بأنه أحد الأصول القيمة والضرورية
من تحدى نيران العدو وأنقذ بلا شك
حياة الأمريكيين والأفغان
على حد سواء
هذا هو إيلي كان أحد أعضاء فريقنا
هؤلاء الرجال  هل كان إخوانك
الأمريكيون إخوانك الأمريكيون ، نعم
عبد ، يقول إنه ليس لديه أي فكرة عما فعله
خطأ
ولم يتلق أبدًا تفسيرًا ، ورد في
خطاب رفض التأشيرة من سفارة الولايات المتحدة
عدم وجود خدمة مخلصة وقيمة إذا
كان لدينا سلام في أفغانستان
إذا لم أخدمنا
عسكريًا إذا لم يكن الطالبان بعدي ،
فلن أغادر بلدي أبدًا ، وقد تقدم حوالي
18000 أفغاني عملوا في
الجيش الأمريكي بطلب للحصول على
تأشيرات هجرة خاصة ، لكن سي إن إن علمت أنه
من المتوقع منح نصفهم فقط ، تجري
إدارة بايدن محادثات مع عدد  من الدول
التي تعمل
كملاذ آمن أثناء معالجة التأشيرات ،
إشارة واضحة إلى أن الحكومة تدرك جيدًا
التهديد الذي يلوح في الأفق الذي يشكله
طالبان ،
ولكن بالنسبة للأفغان الذين تم رفضهم ،
فإن الخطر
هو تمامًا مثل
سهيل باردو الحقيقي الذي شوهد هنا وهو يرقص لمدة
16  أشهر كمترجم
للجيش الأمريكي
قبل أن يفشل أيضًا في اختبار جهاز كشف الكذب
وتم إنهاء عمله في عام 2012.
كانوا يخبرونه أنك خبير
يا للأمريكيين
أنتم عيون الأمريكيين واه
أنت كافر وسنقتلك في
عائلتك
البالغ من العمر اثنين وثلاثين عامًا سهيل أسرار في
صديقه المقرب وزميله المترجم عبد الله
كلاهما انضم إلى الأفغان اليسار  خلف
الجمعية على
أمل زيادة الوعي
بقضاياهم ولكن في صباح يوم 12 مايو من
هذا العام ،
ترك السيد حائل عبد الله رسالة صوتية
يقول فيها إنه كان يقود سيارته من كابول إلى
المحافظة المضيفة لاصطحاب أخته للاحتفال بالعيد
على الطريقة التي أقام بها طالبان.  انطلقت
نقطة تفتيش
بالبرد ، لكن القرويين
قالوا للهلال الأحمر
إن طالبان أطلقت النار على سيارته قبل أن
تنحرف
وتوقف المسلحين ، ثم جر البرد
من السيارة
وقطع رأسه ،
أخذنا شقيق زحل إلى قبره
على جانب تلة قاحلة.
تذكيرًا بالحياة
العنيفة
في بلد تُركت لخوض
هذه الحرب بمفردها ،
هناك المئات من المترجمين الأفغان الآخرين
الذين تم إنهاء
عقدهم  من
أجل ما يقولون إنه سبب غير عادل
وبينما تقول الحكومة الأمريكية إنها
لن تراجع
تلك القضايا ، فإنهم يخشون أنه إذا
بقوا في أفغانستان
سيكون مصيرهم هو نفس المصير الذي
نطلبه
من الرئيس بايدن لإنقاذنا
نحن ندعم  نحن نساعدك وعليك
أن تساعدنا
في نداء يائس من مجموعة من الأفغان
الذين اعتقدوا ذات مرة أن أمريكا
لن تتخلى عنهم أبدًا.